you and I attended a party at my house
and kids like some right they want to
talk to you they know who you are and
they have questions yeah does my teacher
care and understand what I'm asking I
think adults also have questions where
they forgot how to ask them well because
you never want to look like you don't
know yeah yeah yeah I don't mind being
dumb as hell I don't mind people knowing
I'm dumb as I would tell you I'm dumb as
hell but I try to meet as many people
who can just drop little droplets in my
head just let me know what's happened
there questions that everyone has and
that's how I feel about our place in the
universe you know the idea that we are
the only things out here doesn't make
any sense to me
there would be it's inexcusably
egocentric to even suggest it and isn't
a human is it a human thing is it
American thing I don't know how is human
the history of our species is that one
we are we are certain we are in the
middle you know what does Mediterranean
mean it means Middle Earth Mediterranean
yeah so back then they named the region
because they believe they're in the
middle of the Flat Earth at the time you
know with the announcement recently of
finding where they say a hundred and
twenty other Ordos of 1200 1200
exoplanets okay so that didn't make me
feel better I will tell you because I
don't know where those planets where
they are what are they doing or what it
is on they could have a press release on
their own planet today saying we've just
discovered planets on a thousand systems
including this one over here where they
call themselves earth we could be in
their sky yes I'm thinking about it the
way yeah it about that now
we're not looking to hurt those planets
not initially